cheers the night sighs black they say no
failure to quit can't you see what I
could be a possibility
with just a little courage you could
really be something
I got coverage let's take the trip back
back in the time 1977 it was maximum
profit your natural where Smith we
working for drug dealers
you ever thought of quitting this ain't
Disneyland this is the proxy but it
seemed like nothing found the trouble I
see the light it's right there at the
end of the tunnel
don't push me to be who you want me to
be nobody's asking what I wanna be show
me what you got
you truly are as fine as wine and so
divine you know I had to make you mine
I just say I'm gonna get out
I'm kidding let anybody distract me from
that no daughter of mine is
the way I see all of us here on this
planet I'm on a journey and it is a
mystery
it's about music man it'll move forward
and open up doors and everyone says a
shut but give you the homework for free
if you just hold back nothing you hear
that that is life and destiny that is
the get down
like the most
I came from the city back in the time
1977 it was maximum trust approach we
had the bubble with rivals on the